how did you get told did you get like
the [ __ ] banana
no it was so embarrassing this woman
right is she was like have you seen
matilda in that movie yeah
like what's that that that woman called
the like the devil teacher in the car
literally woman looked like that dead
ass
took out this like [ __ ] 12-inch dildo
smacked it on the table
and she was like who wants to put a
condom on this who wants to try
and then everyone was like what the [ __ ]
why is it so big
that was massive it was huge so i got
this from my own collection
that was right that was why i like that
i remember that i went home that day and
i'm like
what is average dick size because i was
like i was like that cannot be normal
that is like that is 12 inches that is
just the girth of it was ridiculous
that was clearly her own personal wants
yeah
jesus christ yeah i had to do the banana
yeah i thought i thought that was just
industry standing yeah
maybe there was a banana and she was
like no i'm going to bring my own let me
just bring my ann summers like [ __ ]
[ __ ] collection
so like where are we going because i
think what happened was they ended up
teaching it like
we had so much of it because where i
grew up was like the worst place
in uh the uk for teen pregnancies all
right there's so many there's so many
that happened where i grew up
and it was uh yeah obviously you know
the government was like hey guys we know
you're gonna do it just please
please don't have babies yeah yeah yeah
don't
don't do it properly yeah at the right
time remember like a few weeks ago when
i was talking about how my mom
told me that babies came out of the
belly button yeah yeah like
like yeah she she uh she uh watched that
episode and she messages me the day uh
the day afterwards reminding me that
actually my very first sex ed class
which was in primary school i can't
remember how old i was i think i was
like did i have sex
in primary i don't think so i think i
had like a very early sex
yeah it wasn't like i had two or three
during my entire childhood i think and
it just like
every sex had got like progressively
more graphic
like like the older you get which is how
it should be but
she reminded me that the first time i
learned that babies didn't come out of
the belly button
and came out of the you know it came out
of the vagina i dead ass didn't believe
them
i came home and i remember because i
remember i remember this so
vividly because i remember the very
first time i tried lying to my mum
right and it was it was like such a such
an innocent little kid lie
where i went to the toilet and i didn't
wash my hands
and she asked me if i washed my hands
and i said yes
that was the first time and i attempted
a lie in my life
it's like the most vanilla lie and she
was like let me smell your hands
let me store your hands and i'm like oh
[ __ ] the first time i tried lying
i got caught so that was that was
embedded in me
from like from like a very early age
just like people don't lie
because people get caught when they're
live so yeah yeah
so sometimes you believed your mom yeah
so my mom's like
all right i won't punish you this time
but
let's just make a promise that we're
just not going to lie to each other
ever and i like me bright-eyed like
five-year-old i believed her until like
i hit
uh i hate teenage hood so i go to this
class and people were and their teachers
were telling us
how babies came out of the vagina and
i'm just like
um actually
um actually miss i believe that they
actually come out of the belly button
i know this my mom taught me no
and she was trying to sell me no they
come they come out down down there your
mom um
i'm sorry your mother is sorry your mom
is wrong so you know
me being like the eight or ten year old
i'm like okay there are there are two
adults in my life that have said
two different pieces of information i go
back to my home
uh i go back home and i tell my mom mom
the teacher taught me this
she said you are a liar but you know
what you promised me
that we wouldn't lie to each other so i
believe you no
i believe you mother i know that babies
come out of the
belly button and she's just like
yeah she just reminded me that that was
a thing i can't actually remember when i
realized that babies didn't come out the
belly button
master just blanked that out yes thank
you mother for lying to me from a young
age
i know you're a liar now